hello everyone and welcome to the video
on large language models large language
models are basically very Advanced
artificial intelligence systems that can
process and generate massive amounts of
text Data they are designed to learn
from and understand natural human
language and can be used to perform a
wide range of language related tasks
such as translation speech recognition
and automatic summary generation one of
the key advantages of large language
models is their ability to learn from
vast amounts of data which allows them
to generate highly accurate and
realistic responses to complex natural
language prompts additionally they can
be trained on multiple languages
simultaneously which means they can be
used to perform language translation
between different pairs of languages
making them an invaluable tool for
businesses and organizations that work
with people from diverse cultural
backgrounds not just language related
tasks but llms can also have the
potential to revolutionize Fields such
as research science and Healthcare by
allowing researchers to quickly analyze
and process vast amounts of complex X
data they can accelerate progress in
areas such as drug Discovery Healthcare
Diagnostics and AI development that
being said large language models also
present some challenges for instance
they require a significant amount of
compute resources which can be
prohibitively expensive for some
organizations additionally because they
are trained on huge amounts of data they
may inadvertently reinforce biased or
discriminate the patterns in language
use which is something that researchers
and Engineers are continuously working
to address overall large language models
are an exciting and rapidly developing
field with tremendous potential to
transform the way we live work and
communicate so if you want to embark on
a journey of AI and ml then try giving a
show to a postgraduate program in Ai and
ml that is in partnership with IBM this
artificial intelligence course covers
the latest tools and Technologies from
the AI ecosystem and features master
classes by Caltech faculty and IBM
experts hackathons and ask me anything
sessions this program showcases Caltech
ctm is excellence and I IBM's industry
progress the artificial intelligence
course covers key Concepts like
statistics data science with python
machine learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions enroll now analog exciting Ai
and ml opportunities the link is
mentioned in the description box below
and with that having said hey everyone
welcome to Simply learns YouTube channel
but before we dive into that don't
forget to like subscribe and share in
this video we'll cover topics like what
are large language models after that
we'll look at what large language models
used for and after that we'll cover how
are large language models trained after
this we'll look at how do large language
models work and at the last we'll see
some applications of large language
models so without any further Ado let's
get started
so we'll start with what are the large
language models large language models
such as gpd3 generative pre-trained
Transformer 3 Advanced artificial
intelligence systems designed to
understand and generate human-like text
these models are built using deep
learning techniques and have been
trained on vast amounts of text Data
from the internet these models use
self-attention mechanisms to analyze the
relationships between words or tokens in
a text enabling them to capture
contextual information and generate core
entry responses these models use
self-attention mechanisms to analyze the
relationship between different words or
tokens in the text enabling them to
capture contextual information and
generate core and responses these models
have significant implications for a wide
range of applications including virtual
assistants chat boards content
generation
language translation and aiding in
research and decision making processes
their ability to generate coherent and
contextually appropriate text has led to
advancement in natural language
understanding and human computer
interaction
now we'll see what are language models
used for
so large language models are utilized in
scenarios where there is limited or no
domain specific data available for
training these scenarios include both
few short and zero short learning
approaches which rely on the model's
strong inductive bias and its capability
to derive meaningful representations
from a small amount of data or even no
data at all
now we'll see how our large language
models trained large language models
typically undergo pre-training on abroad
while encompassing data set that shares
statistical similarities with the data
set specific to the Target task the
objective of pre-training is to enable
the model to acquire high level features
that can later be applied during the
fine tuning phase for specific tasks and
the training process of a large language
model involves several steps the first
is text pre-processing the textual data
is transformed into a numerical
representation that can be effectively
processed by the model this conversion
may involve techniques like tokenization
encoding and creating input sequences
the next we have is random parameter
initialization the model's parameters
are initialized randomly before the
training process begins the next is
inputting numerical data the numerical
representation of Text data is fed into
the model for processing the model's
architecture typically based on
Transformers allows it to capture the
contextual relationships between the
words and tokens in the text and the
next is Lowe's function calculation a
loss function is employed to measure the
discrepancy between the model's
predictions and the actual next word or
token in a sentence the model aims to
minimize this loss during training and
the next is parameter optimization the
model's parameters are adjusted through
optimization techniques such as gradient
descent to reduce the loss this involves
calculating radians and updating the
parameters accordingly gradually
improving the model's performance and
the next is iterative training the
training process is repeated over
multiple iterations or epochs until the
model's outputs achieve a satisfactory
level of accuracy on the given task or
data set by following this training
process large language model learn to
capture linguistic patterns understand
context and generate coherent responses
enabling them to excel at a wide range
of language related tasks and now we
will see how do large language models
work so large language models leverage
deep neural networks to generate outputs
based on patterns learned from the
training data
typically a large language model adopts
a Transformer architecture which enables
the model to identify relationships
between words in a sentence irrespective
of the position in the sequence in
contrast to referent neural networks
that is rnns that rely on recurrence to
capture token relationships Transformer
neural networks employ self-attention as
their primary mechanism
self-attention calculates attention
scores that determines the importance of
each token with respect to other tokens
in the text sequence facilitating the
modeling of intricate relationships
within the data now we'll see
applications of large language models
last language models have wide range of
applications across various domains and
here are some notable applications the
first one is natural language processing
large language models are used to
improve natural language understanding
tasks such as sentiment analysis named
entity recognition text classification
and language modeling the next is chat
boards and virtual assistants large
language models power conversational
agents chatbots and virtual assistants
providing more interactive and
human-like interactions with users and
the next is machine translation large
language models have been used for
automatic language translation enabling
the translation of text between
different languages with improved
accuracy and the next we have is
sentiment analysis large language models
can analyze and classify as a sentiment
or emotion expressed in a piece of text
which is valuable for market research
brand monitoring and social media
analysis and the next we have is content
recommendation these models can be
employed to provide personalized content
recommendations enhancing user
experience and engagement on platforms
such as news websites or streaming
services these applications highlight
the versatility and potential impact of
large language models in various domains
improving language understanding
Automation and interaction between
humans and computers and with that we
have reached the end of this tutorial if
you have any questions please feel free
to comment and will have it answered for
you as soon as possible until next time
thank you for watching stay safe keep
learning and get ahead staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign